seared with a stamp of approval San
Daniele II prosciutto is widely regarded
some Italy's finest the salted and dry
cured corpse been made for thousands of
years doctors even prescribe it to
patients as a source of protein where
the meat is cured San Daniele II even
has its own prosciutto festival but
makers of the meat are being denied
access to one major export market the
United States for their productivity the
prosciutto we sent to the US is kept
separate and can't come into contact
with our Italian prosciutto
it's as if Al's had the plague they lie
together in the same warehouse but you
have to leave one empty road between
them I just don't understand why the US
has a zero tolerance for a bacteria
naturally found in cured meat hysteria
monocytogenes if prosciutto makers want
to export to the States
they have to reorganize production as if
their factories were on US soil facing
up to 4,500 checks a year the pig
farmers have to adapt to it bubbles us
farmers because we undergo a myriad of
checks and strict controls so creates
problems for both us and the prosciutto
makers while the u.s. Listeria limit is
zero the European standard allows a
hundred units per gram the group
representing the prosciutto makers
suggests the US is overreacting
leprechauns with that mysterious to
humans up millions of units per gram
this shows us the European standard is
very safe in the meantime good news for
the pigs and for us Europeans Tom Gibson
Bloomberg